quand on dit les boumeurs on dise plutôt
une époque mais pas forcément des
personnes en particulier
il n'y a pas de volonté d'opposer là
dessus simplement il faut distinguer le
débat ne se situe pas sur le même plan
pour les jeunes et les plus âgés
même alors c'est vrai que ces catégories
sont un peu floues mais bon disons les
jeunes et les plus âgés
les jeunes sont les premières victimes
économiques les plus âgés sur les
premières victimes physiques alors c'est
très complexe et on l'a dit pour une
pour nos décideurs de concilier ces deux
intérêts qu'ils sont contradictoires et
vous l'avez dit les premières victimes
économiques ce sont les plus jeunes
ggd beaucoup d'exemples d'amis qui ont
perdu qui ont perdu leur emploi pendant
pendant cette période il ya un jeune sur
six qui a perdu son emploi pendant
depuis le début de la crise pourquoi
parce que les entreprises elles font là
justement sur les contrats courent les
cdd
or les contrats courent c'est
essentiellement des jeunes aux états
unis on n'a pas encore les chiffres pour
la france mais aux états unis
vous allez maintenant 52 % des jeunes
qui vivent chez leurs parents
les 18 29 ans et cinq points de plus
qu'au début de la crise il ya également
ceux qui rentrent sur le marché de
l'emploi ya sept cent mille jeunes qui
rentrent sur le marché de l'emploi
sept cent mille jeunes c'est exactement
le chiffre d'emplois qui ont été
détruits depuis des plaques et nous
avaient potentiellement 1 4 millions de
chômeurs donc il s'agit pas de d'opposer
mais simplement situer le débat qui est
complexe évidemment parce que les
intérêts sont contradictoires et c'est
aussi la difficulté de cette crise qui
dépasse tout le monde mais les victimes
économiques sont est essentiellement les
jeunes
lorsque vous êtes à la retraite nous
avaient pas votre niveau de vie
économique ne change pas il n'y a pas
d'évolution
lorsque vous êtes un jeune actif votre
niveau de vie évoluent si vous perdez
votre emploi voilà ce que nous disons
[Musique]